what's your name Michael Michael such a
pleasure I feel like I'm stuck in my
work I got a good job of making 50 Cent
amount of money but like I'm not
passionate about it at all I'm looking
working long hours to look at this stuff
and I don't know what I want to do
really yeah so I think what you do is
you really ask yourself what things most
get you going music Sports food video
games
selling stuff on Amazon just anything
just so I could just get out from the
job and don't feel over pressure to quit
just yet you're so young yeah like
you're so sick yeah bro like you could
do this thing for another two years and
be practical and get a paycheck and then
at 28 find the thing you want yeah so
don't put overdue pressure on yourself
to quit now with no answer quitting with
no answer is unacceptable not fighting
to find an answer is unacceptable you
like that one you like that that caught
you right that's I thought that was a
good one too
because it's the truth
stay well